[Music]
dialogue gives the story color makes it
exciting and moves it forward
romeo oh wilt thou leave me so
unsatisfied
juliet
what satisfaction can stow have tonight
romeo
the exchange of thy love's faithful vows
for mine
without dialogue
so
what goes into writing effective
dialogue
well
there are social skills
making friends solving conflicts being
pleasant and polite
we won't be using any of those today
instead we'll be working on let's call
them anti-social skills
if you're a writer you may already have
a few of these
the first is eavesdropping
if you're riding a bus and hear an
interesting conversation you could write
it all down
of course when you write fiction you're
not describing real people you're making
up characters
but sometimes the words you overhear can
give you ideas
i did not says one person
i saw you the other replies
who might be saying those words
maybe it's two kids in a class and the
boy thinks the girl pushed him
maybe it's a couple but one of them is a
vampire and the woman vampire saw the
man flirting with a zombie or
maybe not
maybe the characters are a teenager and
his mother and they're supposed to be
vegetarians but the mother saw him
eating a burger
so let's say you've decided on some
characters this is anti-social skill
number two start pretending they are
real
what are they like where are they from
what music do they listen to spend some
time with them
if you're on a bus think about what they
might be doing if they were there too
would they talk on the phone listen to
music draw pictures sleep
what we say depends on who we are an
older person might speak differently
than a younger person
someone from the south might speak
differently than someone from the north
once you know your characters you can
figure out how they talk
at this stage it's helpful to use
anti-social skill number three muttering
to yourself when you speak your
character's words you can hear whether
they sound natural and fix them if
necessary remember most people are
usually pretty informal when they speak
they use simple language and
contractions so
do not attempt to lie to me sounds more
natural as don't try to lie to me
also keep it short people tend to speak
in short bursts not lengthy speeches
and let the dialogue do the work ask
yourself
do i really need that adverb for
instance your money or your life
she said threateningly
here threateningly is redundant so you
can get rid of it but if the words and
the actions don't match an adverb can be
helpful
your money or your life she said
lovingly
so to recap
first eavesdrop next pretend imaginary
people are real
finally mutter to yourself and write it
all down
you already have everything you need
this is fictional dialogue or how to
hear voices in your head